another thing that happens because I see
this quite a bit myself in my inbox yeah
is the the average guy that's coming
home every night
when he gets cheated on he gets cheated
on with a guy that's that other dude and
he's sitting there being loyal and being
a good man Etc yeah and and she's
sliding in some footballers inbox yeah
and if he bites and she's foolish enough
to believe it'll be anything more than
just sex then she tried she but she'll
probably just do the sex and
at the same time she would leave him for
that footballer yeah it's ugly it is
ugly and I'm not saying I like it but
it's absolutely true look I'm not
on women I'm just saying when
that guy gets cheated on about because
women cheat too yeah